hey everybody welcome to live-streaming
with live coding with Jessie and today
we're just going to continue on with
what we were doing yesterday I haven't
yeah I don't think I've done anything
since yesterday it's been working on
other things so there's nothing to catch
you up on
only if you haven't seen any of these
the last two streams we're working on an
application page so it's basically just
a big forum a really big forum well it's
a big forum and this is running in
Salesforce which is a platform that a
lot of businesses use in particular the
type of page in Salesforce is called a
visualforce page and they have this
templating system I think they call it
Apex it has these apex tags and we'll
see that in a minute when we get to the
code but today we're not really going to
be messing too much with that we're
gonna deal almost exclusively with CSS
maybe maybe completely CSS so this
should be nice for those of you that
maybe aren't really confident in you
know your JavaScript skills or using you
know frameworks JavaScript frameworks
you might be a little bit more confident
with your CSS skills so should be able
to follow along a little bit better and
I'll try to explain everything as I go
along and explain the reason why I'm
changing the styles and and how I'm
doing it all right
okay so I'm just getting my my other
screens ready they gave everything ready
so let's get started I'm gonna start
this timer I have all of our tasks here
that we're gonna work on so we're just
gonna work our way down this to-do list
and see how many we can get get finished
and really this to-do list includes
pretty much everything that we need to
do to complete this project so this
might be the last day that we're working
on it
we'll see you ever know for sure
occasionally you run into some things
that she didn't realize we're there or
we didn't realize would be a problem I
already see something I forgot forget to
we're gonna make that logo larger all
right let's start with that actually
because that's right here at the top in
the corner here so I usually like to
kind of start with the header anyway and
then work my way down so we'll probably
start with this get this completed and
then we'll work over to this side side
nav here will complete the styles on
that and then we'll finish up a few
things that need done within the form
itself okay so let's take a look then
whoops in progress
and let's take a look at what's going on
here and why it's so small
okay so we have a container div
try to see what with where is it giving
these let's just go down one and see
okay it looks like it's getting these
from here yep okay interesting so
there's some media queries being used
here that's defining the width of that
icon and the height so let's move this
around a bit and see what changes with
these media queries okay they don't have
any smaller yeah they do it just changed
it yeah okay 768 pixels we change once
we get down here the logo just there's a
good set to display none I'm gonna think
about changing that you probably should
change that but for now let's let's
stick to the task here let's change this
first and so what we'll do is grab this
we may as well keep this media query
because maybe we will want a smaller
logo on a smaller screen we'll see we it
may be the case that we can just keep
the same size on both screens but it'll
save us a little bit of typing later on
if we just bring that media query right
over okay so let's see I'm gonna keep
this with the nav but within that bar
style so when I get down here I'm gonna
make another section within here just
just in in my comments and call this the
interior nav
let's so sentir your top nav because we
do have a side nav and we don't once
when you copy media queries from dev
tools it doesn't get everything that you
need so if you copy it over and it's not
working it's probably because you don't
have that other set of brackets so if
you notice when I when I brought it in
it just had the media query and it did
not have these little curly brackets so
I had to add them so if you've been
working with dev tools I'm sure you've
already encountered that but it might
save you a little bit of frustration at
some point why am i okay shoot I was
editing directly the wrong file so let
me copy this over I wondered what my
indentation was like that and that's why
it's wrong file so luckily we didn't
change that much pretty easy to copy
that over and so now that we I know we
have that in there let's kind of mess
with this now and then we can put in the
new values when we get what we want here
so I'm just going to change the width
and let's do height:auto that's
interesting
very interesting okay 100% Wow
okay we're gonna have to let's go with
this then we'll select the heights
interesting
I am going to have to set I thought it
was odd that they were setting both the
width and the height like that evidently
the way they have this set up you have
to do it so let's let's try it okay
actually that looks fine I just kind of
guessed and figure you have to adjust
this but I think that looks fine alright
let's keep those those numbers then so
we got 150 and 113 I forgot to mention
the beginning I merged another pull
request on our other project on our
bulletin project that we were using
react and graph QL doing some password
lists log in through through email links
so Harshad had another pull request and
he implemented a print view I have a lot
of people who are used to printing the
bulletin from back in the days when it
was just a Word document and they still
want to print it so shortly after I
launched the current version of the
bulletin I decided to implement a
printer-friendly view and so that's why
we had this I really do want to keep it
because I had several people ask very
politely for it so thank you harsh it
for implementing that view it looks
great I issued about that just to add in
a few things and fix some positioning
things so I think we already have
someone who's Whelan's here to to do
that so thank you for that I can't
remember the name off the top of my head
but you know who you are if you're
watching so I appreciate that
okay that's not bad while we're here
let's just check out well let's just go
really big
okay that works that works just kind of
making sure we don't have a third media
query and it looks like we don't so when
we get down to here though I think I'd
like to display the logo and that may
require us to make this header a bit
bigger I'm okay with that though I think
it's important that we we still have
some continuity with our branding even
on the interior pages and I know that my
bosses would agree about that so that's
what we'll do
I let's see if we need to set yeah all
right well let's set our within our
height like we did last time
let's go with let's try 100 okay I guess
we won't need to with this this time
just the height so first thing I'm gonna
try to make this small that's
interesting
alright we're gonna have to change the
background sighs I could have typed that
out faster then it took me a tab down
there so we need to change the
background size here whoops background
sighs let's see interesting
we are
there we go it would just wasn't working
because I was putting it on the wrong
thing okay there we go this is what
background has contained there we go
okay so this is what we have here let's
see that that small but that will be on
a mobile device so I think it's you know
potentially it's reasonable to have a
smaller logo a user will have the device
closer to their face than they would a
computer screen or something like that I
think that works I think we're gonna go
with that and if we get some feedback
that it needs to be bigger we can always
do that but we'll go with this and then
we won't even have to mess with the
height okay that works so let's go let's
just double check and make sure that we
can put this height here and it still
works and it does we're gonna grab these
two let's just grab the whole thing here
okay and we're still within our our top
and a half here and let's put this here
the media query below it you know what
I'm gonna keep this here even though
we'll be we already have it elsewhere
because I just like to keep all of my
custom styles in the same spot and then
I can remove this from the area where I
had this previously okay great so let's
do a little test and copy these over
and then we'll copy it over into
Salesforce make sure that all our styles
are being applied correctly
okay
oh okay and that is not being applied
correctly
that's all that's
all right let's let's do a hard refresh
here okay maybe I messed something up
when I copy and paste of this okay
that's that's there it's definitely
there
alright let's try it again then copy and
paste and quicksave okay
try it again
alright let's inspect it should be this
style tag yep
alright let's go down to this place yeah
actually so we do we have this we have
these styles here why aren't they being
applied target X header University icon
um let's try this
I'm not 100% sure this is the problem
but it's worth a shot
nope thought it might have been throwing
an error okay well let's see let's see
if the other one is being applied nope
it's not interesting all right let me
check the live chat in case you all saw
something that that I didn't see oh no I
forgot to start my timer I even moved it
over here in the corner so you all can
see it and I forgot we're gonna have to
keep an eye on the clock but 218 right
now let me set this 10-minute timer and
that'll be right about the time when I
started coding so thanks for for asking
about that Harshit let me check hey
everybody I see several of you were
saying hello
haha alright it says I now have 41
commits in the bulletin you have 21 I
know I know you've done quite a bit of
work I am I told everyone and we had a
department meeting yesterday and I told
everyone that I you were doing a
significant amount of the work for this
bulletin and they were all impressed so
so I'm not taking credit for your work
making sure that that everyone here
knows not just the work that Harsha does
but the work that all of you do so I do
not mind sharing credit at all okay
Sebastian says I see some angular stuff
there yeah there's some angular going on
here
so yeah this this is built with with
angular oops it's not showing up
properly when it's small yeah so let's
see yeah so we've got angular here and
jQuery the moment for the dates and then
here's that Apex pages that's a
Salesforce thing yeah speaking of
angular we had a new video out this past
week setting up an angular project so if
you're interested in angular check that
out I never really do any angular stuff
so for any angular people that might be
watching you can check that video out it
it's one of just check the the last like
several videos it'll be in there the
title is really obvious but that's
really cool cuz we didn't we didn't
really have a lot of angular stuff going
on until now shoot all right let's
troubleshoot this hmm okay so I'm gonna
check let me look in this style tag
again to see if we've made any mistakes
actually let me see this I believe is
being applied correctly where's our a
tag okay here so our a tag is being
applied correctly I'm basically trying
to see how far down the page is there an
error
[Music]
hmm
all right let's all right so that's way
at the top yeah that's way way to talk
I'm thinking did we miss I'm thinking we
messed up our syntax somewhere but just
it doesn't look like it these are all
things we did yesterday that worked the
only things that we've added but this
year so
I'm not 100% sure this is entirely
necessary but I I see that almost always
so MIT it's worth a shot I don't see how
that could have messed up the previous
code though the previous Stiles okay
you know what let's let's inspect that
element
we're gonna have to expand this so I can
get that okay so that's alright
yeah in Hughes
okay so that's already showing up in the
page and it's at the bottom okay we've
got some things overriding our styles so
let's take that out completely or we can
comment it up these are all commented
out so that's fun
okay so let's dig in to Salesforce a bit
and find where this is is being put in
and let's take it out let's see okay
so let me think all right let's go into
our our visualforce pages sorry this is
so small I'll try to make it bigger the
medium crease the font size okay we need
action is that we may be able to get
this quickly if I go back to the main
page sometimes it'll show me what I've
there we go
default I think this is it yep yeah this
is it - anyway it shows my recent item
so luckily I had checked this page out
recently enough that it was still here
save me a lot of time looking for it
okay wow that's so useful for custom CSS
as sarcasm really I mean how can you put
custom CSS and the box of the small I
know you can resize it but the default
should be like at least that big okay
let's just comment this out
the reason I'm commenting it out and not
taking it out completely is that this
this was put in here by the company
that's doing this so target X is the
company that made this application
portion that works with Salesforce but
then another company called Jenzabar is
reselling that to my University so we
don't work directly with target X we
work with Jenzabar so the ghent the
person at Jenzabar that's in charge of
helping us left all this code here as a
little helper
so that I didn't have to look for where
to do these things so that's why I'm
leading it here in case I ever get stuck
and don't know where to change something
I can come back here and it's all you
know has some helpful comments so that's
why I'm keeping it like that otherwise I
would just get rid of it okay all right
now let's refresh and see what happens
haha not expected at all
okay I didn't think that would happen
because I thought we yeah we are
bringing in that background image here
alright let's see maybe this is being
inserted somewhere else further down the
page as well interesting okay this is a
good sign though no it's not that's the
old stuff we're still not getting any of
our newer stuff
okay finally here we did get some of the
new stuff here okay so you see it is
being that's really odd okay we just
need to get a little bit more specific
with our style so I'm not gonna even
look at these anymore let's just let's
just do this I mean I don't really like
doing this often but this isn't a usual
situation where we have access to all
the files and my timer just went off so
I'm going to test this and no matter
what happens we're just gonna answer
some questions oh okay we have something
all right great
this is very slow to update I mean on
how many people are gonna be moving this
back and forth like that but okay I'm
not exactly sure why this isn't working
here oh you know we forgot to take out
display:none as soon as we get back from
the question/answer we got to remember
display:none needs to be changed to
display whatever we want we'll see which
display works the best there okay short
break and I'm gonna go through the live
chat answer any questions that you've
had so far then we'll do another
25-minute session we'll finish up with
that header should be just one more
thing needed for the change and let's
mark down that we did spend so far one
Pomodoro cycle on that okay let's see
hard [ __ ] asks okay some gist jitan says
can you read this yes I can read
this so let me know if you have any
other questions of more than happy to
answer them and welcome I haven't seen
you in the chat before so thanks for
joining us so hard should I ask if
there's any big work left in the
bulletin project like authentication I
might do that this weekend you know what
hard should I I'll think I'll think
about some stuff and maybe put some
issues in and if I think about what I'm
streaming I'll I'll say something maybe
in the question and answer session at
the end we can take a look at the site
quickly and maybe go over some things
and that way you or anybody else that
wants to work on it over the weekend can
do that I as I said before about that
project I really want to tie it into the
login system that we have at the
University it's saml-based I just I need
to get some information from the IT
department I can't implement that I
can't do anything from my end unless I
get the right info so I'm still working
on that info I do have a meeting and the
head of the IT department and the
second-in-command that the IT department
will be there but it's not until
November 7th it's about something else
but I could definitely ask them if I
haven't got the info by then I hope I
get the info sooner than that but I
don't have very much hope that you know
it's it's 2:30 p.m. here on a Friday so
I don't think I did very much done now
if I especially after the stream
everybody would probably be gone so
probably next week I'll reach out to
them again and maybe meet with some of
them and talk about it so there is more
authentication work that that needs to
be done I hope but I don't really have
enough info right now for us to get it
to work or test it out or anything like
that
Harshit also asked what's the plan for
deployment of the bulletin okay I don't
have a date yet for deployment so yeah
so in terms of a date there's no hard
you know date for that when we do deploy
we're going to deploy it just like we've
done in some of the previous projects
we're gonna have we're going to set up a
droplet on digital ocean with Ubuntu
we're obviously running node we're gonna
run nginx as a reverse proxy we'll set
up an ssl with that and probably it will
end up being a bulletin Franciscan
University and then we'll just set up a
redirect for the current URL because the
current URL is Franciscan University /
bulletin but with the way we have things
set up ladies I can't do that if we want
to put this on digitalocean so we'll
just set up a redirect for the current
URL to redirect to the other one and yes
I mean it's not really anything we
haven't worked on before we don't need
it to handle a really heavy load you
know the university has around 500
employees and so there's not really
going to be that many people on this
site at any one time so we should be
able to just to run a five dollar
droplet
now I should said try important to
override I know I try to avoid using
important whenever I can though so it
would it may be have saved some time and
we may end up having to resort to that
anyway but since in that case I could
get rid of some code and I was going to
get rid of that code anyway at some
point I figured we may as well do that
it makes everything look a lot cleaner
in the end rooks said what is that a CSS
CSS box for ants it needs to be at least
three times bigger I know right
it was crazy like maybe they just don't
expect people to even use that and so
they just made it small let's say I only
have a few more comments left so I know
my timers up but I'll just get through
the rest of them inna says how was your
day Jesse actually today wasn't bad
actually if you all don't mind I mean
let me tell you a story for two minutes
here because I did have a little
excitement today so I come into work and
I'm working for a little while and then
I get a call from my wife who says she
was upstairs with with the two littlest
ones with the baby and with my
three-year-old and all of a sudden she
heard the door alarm go off so I have a
alarm on the house and even if the
alarms not said it still makes a noise
like a doorbell annoys when somebody
opens the door and then a voice says
which door was open so it said the
basement door came open so she looked
out the window to see if I was home
didn't see my car got scared and took
the kids and ran it across the street to
the neighbor's house who I guess my wife
has the code for their garage door
opener because she takes care of their
dog whenever they're away so she goes
over the neighbors house and calls me
I'm at work I'm saying well I don't know
what to do I'll just
come check it out so I drove home went
through the whole house to make sure
nobody was there nobody was there I
think what happened is my wife just was
holding the baby when she came in and
did not close the door and you know just
kind of it closed but it didn't latch
all the way so the wind probably blew
and blew it open but anyway uh-huh
I had to go home and and protect my my
family so but I did get to see the baby
and my three-year-old and my wife so
that was kind of cool I got to see them
so anyway so that's how my day was so
far and yeah not bad I've been a I wrote
a gist that fixed what I think was an
error in materialized CSS I wrote this a
long time ago and I just just now the
the maintainer czar their post we don't
think that it's a problem they think
that it's not a bug and it should be
like that so anyway we disagree on that
point but I still put my gist in the
issue so that other people could use it
if they were having the same problem so
anyway I've been going back and forth
with someone on there trying to help
them to use that so that's kind of cool
because I like I mean I took the time to
put that on there so I'm really happy
that somebody's actually using that
although I do kind of wish they put it
they merge it but I mean hey it's their
repo they can run it however they want
anyway thanks for being patient through
my story let's get back to the code
actually meet so harsh it says may I
submit a pull request having sam'l
boilerplate yeah definitely yeah I mean
that'll that'll set us up that it'll be
easier later on when we do get the info
we need so yeah for sure
I appreciate that
Harshit says consider vulture comvee ult
are calm it's cheaper than digitalocean
okay has anybody use that website before
V ult are calm let me know if you have
and how you like it I just got to make
sure that it's it's good quality since
it's for the University I I got to be
able to justify to the IT department
while we're using this and is it safe
and who else uses it and they're very
security conscious so anyway as long as
it's all cool and it checks out I'm
definitely open to it but I mean for the
university of five dollar droplet on
digital ocean is not really a huge
expense although I'm personally I'm more
than happy to try it out for my side
projects and things alright let's go
back to this first things first where's
that display:none get out of here
alright okay cool so display:none was
our problem let's get rid of that and
say whoops what do we want to say let's
see what it it's automatically going to
hear display:block all right great
we will set it to display block where we
add
oh right here very what my cursor is on
what I'm thinking
display:block all right I'm not even
going to check that I'm almost positive
that it's gonna work
actually now I'm not I'm gonna check it
now I don't remember before the the
break exactly how much we we worked out
in terms of the overrides
it's okay looks like it worked wonderful
alright let's move let's move this over
to the done right we've already tested
it now it's done I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna change this amount of time we took
since we only went over by a minute or
so all right so next one fix button
colors on the application of let's go
for that all right and then let's put
all these side nav ones on deck here and
ready for dev saina saina saina
okay
so the button colors obviously are not
what we want let's think about what
color we want do we want to go with the
yellow I think it's either going to be
that yellow color or with a green color
hmm I think I'll go with the yellow for
now since we're already using it for the
other buttons just for consistency and
then we can always change it later if we
if we feel like we need to forget X
button header okay let's grab that class
and as you can see I've been editing in
this file so I think I think I'm just
gonna edit in this file to take out one
step from our flow here and then I don't
know at the end of every day I can just
copy it over here if we really want to
keep a separate CSS file but I think it
might be better to just keep all this in
style tag in the head like we're doing
since that's the way we're building it
and testing it then it's most likely to
be reliable like this I'm afraid if we
move it into an external CSS file and
then bring it in it it'll get overridden
by a lot of other styles and we'll have
a mess
okay where mine is my button styles
that's not it
I think they're down here there we go
button styles let's add this in oops
and we're gonna add it in here as well
all right
so that should do it
let me make this a bit smaller
whoa
interesting
all right so that didn't work probably
let's see I'm guessing that the styles
interesting
all right are they have going on here
all right let's I think we're gonna have
to use important here so it looks like
the hover is working so that is turning
a different color but we're gonna have
to use important for the non hover State
so so important on our color and on our
background color if you're not familiar
with important important overrides
everything in CSS so even in line styles
so if you really need something to apply
use that but use it sparingly because
you'll never be able to change this it
totally breaks the cascading nature of
cascading style sheets so normally you
want the cascading yeah so that's why I
try not to use it because it makes
things difficult later on to change but
sometimes you have to do it and in this
case I don't think we have another
option unless we want to take a lot of
time to try to find out where all this
markup is coming from and change that
and I don't think it's that important to
take that much time
okay interesting so we still have some
things that aren't being applied
we still have that weird effect which I
definitely want to get rid of we have
this is that supposed to be a shadow or
a border that's weird
let's see where that's coming from
oh my goodness it's a blue box shadow
wow I've never seen anything like that
that's a weird shadow too I mean aside
from the color it's just really odd
anyway okay so we're gonna have to get
rid of that box shadow why is it not Oh
where is this being pulled in from
grid framework I got to see where on the
page this is coming in it
no just no finding this
for some reason the search is not
working come on
actually you know what I think it's
searching there we go
interesting it must be being pulled in
some other way
alright let's find all our style tags
six-six style tags you gotta be kidding
me
alright there's nothing in that one this
one's above ours we need to look for
ones that are below our style tags so
I'm sorry
that's a script tag now that's weird so
we have our head tag here and then we
have our body but then within our body
we have a bunch of meta stuff and more
tags ah that's a mess okay so we've got
our first one our second one third one
is ours the fourth one
okay so I don't think we're dealing with
any of these yet but it's good to know
it's there now we should have one more
and we already commented all this out
that's really odd let me check the live
chat here and see if you all saw
anything that I didn't yeah hard [ __ ]
you're right it is a source map that's
why I started to look in here manually
because I thought well here's what I
thought of one that it is a source map
because it had the dot less at the end
right but I thought even if it's being
pulled in anywhere on this page as as a
link it shouldn't be overriding what
we're doing so maybe somehow they're
pulling it in and putting it inside a
style tag but we can see that's not the
case we just went through every style
tag so yeah let's do that
let me see I'm not I never use source
Maps so I need to figure out where I can
turn this off at
I said I want this there we go
okay all right source maps are off now
hopefully we'll be able to see where
this is really coming from whenever I
work on projects like this that are old
projects that I need to do things with
it feels like I'm a detective
it's like a puzzle like I'm trying to
figure out where the things are it's
kind of fun when it works out not so fun
when you spend hours trying to figure
out something but so far we haven't
really spent that much time trying to
figure anything out where was that
button header there's our button right
all right let's scroll down no all right
let's refresh because it's still showing
me the less file
what's it's still showing less files
no no still gotta be kidding me
all right let me look
all right
hard [ __ ] good good IRS it yeah okay I'm
so glad you saw that I turned off
JavaScript source Maps not CSS source
maps so thank you for catching that hard
[ __ ] I would have been searching for a
long time in vain okay cool
now let's let's give it a refresh whoa
let's go back here
and let's see where this is coming from
okay these are our styles
where is this coming from
I guess these aren't ourselves these are
ours okay I was mistaken these are ours
these are the ones that are overriding
ours and they are in a style tag we just
missed them though they're not what this
is so weird
this should not be overriding our Styles
our styles are down here right I thought
they were I guess not
all right let's go back here oops not
well it'll be easier to see here okay
better nav nav or
I
I really hate to do this because
obviously you don't want to put style
tags in the middle here but I think this
is the only way that we're gonna be sure
that we're overriding a lot of stuff so
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna move
our style tag down here if I put our
style tag right here above the nav we
might have a shot at having it be above
I'd rather not have to put it inside the
nav but if I do I will just it's just
gonna look terrible inside than that but
anyway I think we'll do it now the
reason I I'm gonna do this even though I
wouldn't normally put a style tag in
here is because the way that the
document is being put together the style
tags are already all messed up you have
multiple places throughout where there
are style tags so I don't have control
over that I can't change that so I
shouldn't be too worried about it
okay let's change this and hopefully
this will solve our problem there we go
we can leave our link tag up here that's
fine now let's bring this in save it
copy it and alright now let's see what's
going on
it's how is it worse no what is going on
okay
but none of my styles here now I am us a
copy and paste wrong right that's insane
no that's
okay there's our font dashboard so I get
it you I already check that the style
and these are not it right here's the
one that we wanted to get below here's
our header we should be inside that
hmm
all right for some reason it doesn't
like it that we put that style in here
let's move it somewhere else
all right I'm gonna try it in here
if this doesn't work I may just have to
throw some more importance in there wow
did I copy this over or not now I can't
even remember and let's make sure we do
a hard refresh
style oops gonna check the style tags
yeah we're missing one see before we had
six and now we have five so that style
tag that we're trying to move around
will not work if we put it down lower in
here
so
potentially we could put CSS down at the
bottom here we have this portion here
that's being added it would work I know
where I need to put this but I'm
hesitant it already is taking so long
for the styles to actually get applied
I'd rather not add to that time at all
by moving on the further down the page
hmm all right let's
let's move it back to where we know it
works first of all
all right so you got ourselves back
that'll be a good place to start from
let's do another question and answer
sessions I'm gonna set my my five minute
timer right now but I'm still I'm trying
to fit decide whether or not I want to
do another Pomodoro session of keep
looking the wrong spot of CSS so I'm not
not hundred percent sure this one's
taking way longer than anticipated and I
know I estimated one but I thought it
would be before one okay let me scroll
up a bit and it's actually not a lot in
the live chat so oops maybe we will do
some more some more coding
nan says that styling tags are a mess
yes is they
Harshit a switch mouse and keyboard I
use I use the what do they call it the
magic trackpad or something like that so
the Apple trackpad thing that you can
get with with Macs
so that's what I use the gestures are
nice so it was really weird to get used
to coding with this at first but I've
been using it for about a year and a
half mount and it's just really fast to
like swipe between screens you know and
do things like that so I've gotten used
to it
does anybody else use a trackpad when
they're coding or is it you know mainly
use use a mouse and my keyboard is just
it's nothing special the keyboard is
just the basic Apple keyboard so I mean
it it has the number pad on it that's
the really special thing so I've been
one to try out one of these mechanical
keyboards that I see everybody talks
about how awesome they are so I want to
try it out they're kind of expensive and
a lot of them look really cool so maybe
uh maybe I'll try it out I'll try one
out one day
Harshit said i mostly use keyboard for
us all stuff yeah I've heard that that
that ends up being a lot faster horses I
rarely touched them off yeah that would
be a lot faster I've heard especially
people that use them they like never
need to touch the mouse they can do
everything from the keyboard so that's
cool I can see the benefits of that for
now this this works for me I'd have to
make like a deliberate effort to try to
switch up how I do with the so if I
think it'll really help speed up my my
dev process here then I'm willing to try
something else but for now this works
for me like I said I probably I'd like
to try out a new keyboard but we'll see
I'll just maybe have to wait and see if
one's on sale and it's it's good quality
I really like I've seen some keyboards
that look like they're from a typewriter
so they look really old-school I think
that looks cool I would I would want to
try that or try to make that or
something
rook says hi is that how the screen
sometimes slide halfway across yeah
that's I do the little slide thing so it
is cool and that's one thing like when I
had a mouse I used to do this with the
keyboard I think you can do like control
and then the number keys but one thing
you can't do with that is you can't
slide halfway across and check what's
going on here so like there's you don't
have as much control with the keyboard
for things like this sometimes you like
I don't need like I don't need to go
completely up here I just need to peek
really quick and see what's behind
something so
it's not it's not a huge difference but
it makes a little bit of difference
Sahil says Trello does help yeah
definitely Sal says I mean for one
person on a single project Oh does
Trello help sorry I misread that first
one it's a question the question is does
Trello help for one person on a single
project yeah definitely Trello is very
helpful so this is how I set up all my
Trello boards for for projects that I'm
doing this is the the Kanban style I do
add this column here you don't
technically need all these columns for
for Kanban but this is I like to set it
up and how I learned to do it it's very
helpful for me to keep track of
everything I can easily at a glance see
how much more I have left in my project
how much I've done it's a very nice
visual reminder once this done section
gets really long it's it's cool because
you just get the feeling like I've done
all this work it's a sense of
accomplishment even though you haven't
finished the project yet you can still
see all the work that you put into it
so I recommend this even if you're the
only person on the project it'll keep
you on track and it gives you a nice
record you know in addition to your
commit history and things like that but
this gives you a nice record and it
helps me you know I can i can put to-do
lists in here I can put attachments if I
wanted to I could I could allow somebody
else to see this even if they're not
working on the project maybe like let's
say somebody who's handling the
photography or the content for the site
maybe able to put their stuff in here so
even if they're not a developer still be
useful so anyway I really like this and
I imagine if you had more than one
person this would be even more useful so
that
anybody could automatically see what's
going on with the project and if
somebody's working on something or not
so I like it
it helps me but you have to you just
have to be consistent and use it
occasionally I'll have a project where I
just quit using the board and then
obviously there's you know there's no
benefit to it let's see Harshit says you
can annoy people with them meaning the
mechanical keyboard especially the
Cherry MX red switches okay that's what
that's what I wondered so if any of you
have experience with a mechanical
keyboard let me know so I guess I have
two questions one is the noise really
that bad now I work in an office by
myself I have walls the ceiling a door
so it's probably not the noise issue
won't be a problem when I work at home I
usually work in the basement so probably
not a problem either but I mean is it so
loud that I would hear it over my
headphones and it would annoy I would
annoy me myself right that's my first
question number two if I was to get one
what are the best kinds of switches
because I hear like all these different
colors for switches which ones are the
best
okay so I'll let everybody answer that
and I'll move on here Brian asks how are
you peaking you mean this so hold on a
sec I'll show you
okay all right this will be easier to
see so I move three fingers across like
like this you can't see it on my other
screen because someone I'm a couple
screens over so I just move three
fingers and then I can peek so you need
a trackpad I think you can do it on the
Magic Mouse as well because you can do
touch gestures on the mouse
hello okay the expose gesture that's
three fingers straight up so this one
just move them straight up
okay Robert says read drag red dragon
mechanical keyboard is what I use it's
only $39 I replaced my Corsair with the
red dragon okay that's that's a pretty
reasonable price compared to what I've
seen for for other mechanical keyboards
so so Robert so would you would you
recommend it is it does it give you a
better experience when you're typing is
it a noticeable difference or you know
is it worth it all right rook says the
Cherry MX blue or the clicky
tactile ones okay oh man Sahil says that
once made a Trello board for my friends
for university project but no one even
bothered I know how that is I tried to
get other people that work here to use
Trello for things before nd use like
Google sheets and edit things you know
on the Google sheet instead of emailing
something back and forth or worse
printing it out and just sending it to
people we've actually had people burn
files on CDs to share them and this is
within the last two years so the
situation is I totally understand the
situation of trying to get people to use
some technology that will make things go
faster and be more productive and then
nobody wants to to use it like I'm gonna
make my my face smaller because it just
feel weird I'll leave it a little bit
bigger since I'm talking and not coding
but I was looking at my the the video
feed and just not used to me being the
focus
okay so Robert says there they are noisy
so that use a logitech wave at work
Harshit says some coders do not use
mechanical keyboards on their YouTube
bits and livestream oh that you know
what that's a good idea actually I
didn't even think about that but so it
would probably be good then to have a
either a backup keyboard at work or just
not use it at work and you should use
the if I'm going to use mechanical
keyboard maybe just use it at home
Carson says the Cherry MX brown are the
best okay cool so what what makes the
brown the best sorry for all the
questions about that I'm sure I could
look this up on my own but I think it's
cool to get advice from from you all
especially if you have experience with
them
all right rook says for mechanical
switches go to stores that have them and
fake type away really the best luck
that's a great idea this is just this
kind of goes to show like how much
Amazon has changed the way I think it
never occurred to me that I could go to
an actual store and type on a keyboard
before I bought it
in my mind I'm just thinking like I'm
just gonna buy this off of Amazon like I
the only store I ever actually go to in
person is the grocery store that's
that's it I buy everything else from
Amazon okay Harshit says that corsair
mechanical keyboard costs $170 whew
that's more than I'd like to spend on a
keyboard especially if I already have
one that that is sufficient I would
definitely have to have significant
proof that that keyboard would be much
better for me oh okay so I guess Harshit
saying that now Windows has the same
gestures that's awesome before I am I
downloaded some some program that let me
use gestures on Windows and it wasn't as
good as the Mac but that's really cool
that they have them natively
okay so hard should ask which one do I
find better github or Trello for a
github projects or Trello I'm gonna tell
you right now if I had to pick right now
I'd pick Trello but I'll only use github
projects just for the last what like
week or two so I don't think I've really
given it a fair shot so maybe in a
couple of weeks I'd have a better
opinion if I really force myself to use
get up projects I think if I found a way
on github projects to actually track my
my Pomodoro cycles
then I would probably like it a lot more
so I either need to find something that
does it in a very similar way or better
way that I could do it on Trello or make
something so this is just a chrome
plug-in that does this right now so
potentially I could just make a plug-in
that would do the same thing but for
github pages so if I really start I'm
sorry not github pages github projects
if I really start to like get up
projects maybe I'll make try to make
something like that
I don't know otherwise I'm going to go
I'm going to probably use both and I
it's really nice though that it's
integrated everything with github is
integrated so it's right there on the
repo it's convenient for people who come
to the github repo and want to
contribute to the project and not have
to go somewhere else
so I like that we'll see I really want
github projects to work and be the thing
that I can use so I'm gonna give it I'm
gonna give it some time and and try it
out a little bit more
okay harsh it says for the keyboards
switches the mechanism feels different
for each okay the MX browns are still
tactile but quieter than the blues okay
now our suit says it's personal
preference all right
Robert says I think it's worth it
because I like the tactical feedback I
did not want to pay a hundred dollars to
replace Mike or Sarah so I went with the
red dragon and it works just as good as
the Corsair okay cool so what oh yeah
that was going to be my next question
and you've already answered it so
awesome Robert says the red dragon has
fake red switches so I'm assuming
they're they're not the the Cherry MX
brown switches then they're there
there's some type of off-brand okay
all right cool you know what actually
maybe that might be a good way to start
out just to get a cheaper one even
though it's not like the best switches
that everybody says you need and then at
least I can get an idea of whether I
even like that and then maybe maybe if I
really like it then I can justify paying
more money for the for the chariot brand
switches it could be a work expense I
might be able to deduct that from my
taxes that is another cool thing when
you freelance be sure depending on your
tax laws where you're from you can save
money on your taxes by making sure that
you deduct all work expenses which can
include if you work out of your house
part of your internet bill potentially
even part of your rent if you have a
dedicated working space you know bills
for your computer for all your your
servers you know if you're getting like
digitalocean AWS something like that
so another I didn't talk about that when
we talk about freelancing before but
you're gonna have to deal with taxes if
you freelance unless you pay somebody
else to do it
okay so brooke says the patent expired
on the cherry MX switches so now a lot
of other manufacturers are making them
okay that's kind of cool so potentially
they could be close to the same quality
that's interesting I think it's worth a
shot then I don't know if I'll get it
anytime soon I got Christmas coming up
so I got a save up some money and buy
presents for all the kids and everybody
so maybe after that I'll be looking to
get get a keyboard all right well I'm to
the bottom of the live chat we've been
streaming for about an hour and a half
now so I think I think I'm not gonna do
any more coding it's probably obvious at
this point you know on this stream right
now I'll probably be able to do a little
bit more work on this before I leave
today and I'm gonna do some digging
around in Salesforce because that's kind
of boring for you all to watch I'm gonna
do some digging around and see how much
I can actually edit of this and maybe we
can we can get this looking a little bit
nicer and sort it out so because it's
it's kind of a mess and the mark-up is
just it's weird so oh okay sorry how
should I almost forgot so harsh it's
reminding me that to bring up the
bulletin and plan that out all right
totally forgot really glad you reminded
me all right so I have the bulletin up
right here all right let's see so all
right so aside from the what we already
discussed at the beginning of the stream
about the sam'l authentication stuff
here's what we still need I see they
make a search this way the search is
probably
the biggest most complicated thing that
we need right now so the search I'd like
to have it be a live search so when you
type I mean we definitely want to
debounce it so it doesn't or throttle it
so that it doesn't come up with it
doesn't send like a million requests but
we're gonna have to hit that graph QL
endpoint to get what we need so yeah so
that's what we're gonna do
we'll need some type of live search
feature as a model this live search is
gonna function almost exactly like the
way we did it on project one so I guess
yeah it's gonna function like that
Harshit says there is already data in
there yeah well here's the thing of this
there's a lot of posts so if we can
bring in all of the posts that are in
WordPress then that's fine if we just
filter what we have but do we really
want to pull all those posts every time
somebody comes to the site because
normally people are just going to see a
small fraction of the total available
posts so I guess it's going to be a
trade-off is do we want to keep it
really light and only pull in some of
the posts that people are likely to want
to see and then just make another call
when they go to search or do we want to
pull in everything all the time so I
don't know I don't know what would be
better but either way we need to be able
to get
have you user type something in and then
automatically have these cards pop up so
it would be like basically once they
type in three characters or more if they
stopped for I don't know 400
milliseconds after typing then it runs a
search something like that so anyway
that's their what I'd like to have
happen is if you click search it just
extends it either can do one of two
things you can just extend out a search
box here obviously it needs to be like
the material design style or it can
change out this entire thing and make it
one big search with an X over here and a
search button over here when you click
the button and that's another thing it
needs to happen on first button click it
needs to open up the search and then the
search thing needs to remain here or
slide over and then you need to be able
to click on that to initiate a search
once you've typed in what you want
obviously a live search is it's going to
be an option there and it's going to
automatically come up but the live
search is only going to happen if you
search for something that's three or
more characters on the off chance that
somebody's I've sent two characters and
wants to search for that they need to
hit the search button which why would
you ever search for some those two
characters but you never know maybe it's
two really weird characters okay so
that's the search like I said if you
check out that project one the
catechetical Institute page it's Caddick
etics com I guess we should bring it up
right now so we did this on the
resources page we have the search if you
see I can type that in and right nothing
comes up
so anyway so that's where you'd look for
for that let's see I don't think we're
actually going to do classic mode the
help page we're not going to do that yet
because I think oh that the current help
page is based on the current site so it
has some tutorial videos and things on
there I'm going to redo all that because
we're not going to have the same issues
that we have with the old site so we'll
hold off on that until we're close to
being finished the filter by date so as
long as a user needs to be able to pick
either a month in a year and we just get
all the posts from that particular month
or if we want to we can allow them to
pick a date range so down to the day and
they can pick a date range so either one
of those are fine
probably the month year thing will be
the easiest and then the current
bulletins needs to only get the bulletin
items for the past week I already have
some logic in the current bulletins
project so I'll probably share that
logic with you all sometime next week
and see if we can just recycle that and
apply it to what we're doing here it's
it's a little weird and kind of specific
to our situation so just I guess hold
off on that and until we can look at
what we're doing now and see if that'll
work if we need to to make it better so
anyway that's kind of the plan I think
that covers the biggest things and yeah
I mean I'll be doing a lot of little
adjustments here and there to make
things look nicer or make the text more
readable and things like that you know
just small small adjustments
so cool okay let's see okay heart should
say an Apollo 2 came out interesting I
should said it's crab Redux should we
migrate oh man
I don't know I'm I'm not mice I'm not
necessarily interested in migrating this
project right now since we're already in
the middle of it but I'm open to
suggestions if you all think that I
really should migrate it we can think
about it if any of you want to attempt
to migrate it that's that's totally fine
with me if that's something that you
would like to do and like to try to do
but I'm happy to just leave it as is for
this project and then migrate maybe the
next time we use it we'll use the the
newest version okay all right now I am
at the bottom of the live chat and I'm
really gonna in this time what's today
Friday alright it's Friday so I hope you
all have a nice weekend
I'll be back Monday and hopefully you
all I'd like to see what you all do over
the weekend so I know harsh it's going
to be working on this but I know some of
you have some cool side projects and
things that that you shared with me so I
guess if you're doing any work this
weekend let me know on Monday because
I'm really interested in and seeing what
you are working on and see if we can
help each other out I think it's really
cool you all helped me out on my
projects but if we could all help each
other out that would be awesome as well
so if your stuffs not on github already
put it on github and make some issues
and then on Monday we can go over
that and try to help each other out you
guys can maybe I'll I'll bring up some
of the projects and I think that would
be kind of cool
it'd be like we have our own little team
here you know all right
I can never find the button in the
stream when I want to all right I found
it oh it was great
coding with you and a CEO on Monday